[Music]
or shooting
why can't ring
[Music]
[Music]
someone I have been watching it even
powerless you have led the powerful even
among the legends your name is legendary
am i dead not yet but I can offer you
another
it's time to leave the sidelines
and become the champion you always bet
to me will you accept this challenge
[Music]
we have a great responsibility over this
world
[Music]
the price of freedom is high but we are
willing to pay it I have seen many
futures in all but one war awaits puny
humans are just afraid of home
[Music]
[Music]
Asgardians the glory of allah you human
wizards
oops demigods let's be civil our realms
have been butting heads for a long time
I don't know about you but if fighting a
secret war will prevent an open one I'm
game will you join me the choice is
yours summoner keep hacking at the
branches of evil or find how deep its
roots go
[Music]
go on bald-headed fool send your little
raps help to see it doesn't matter they
cannot escape the title
[Music]